around here on film theory you know
we've covered some pretty bizarre series
on the Internet from episodes on poppy
- salad fingers - don't hug me I'm
scared but today I think I can safely
say that I'm going to the darkest part
of the internet yet hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that's
been youtubing it up since the days of
vine here on the channel I have a
history of covering not just movies and
TV but also big online series that pop
up all across the interwebs and recently
there has been nothing bigger than the
Shane Dawson expose into the life of
Jake Paul in case you weren't one of the
hundred and forty two million views that
this series got in its first couple
weeks let me catch you up recently
youtuber slash conspiracy theorist chain
Dawson put out an 8 part documentary
series on social media star former Viner
and all-around bad boy Jake Paul yes
that's correct
right now you're watching a youtuber
covering a youtuber covering another
youtuber we have reached peak meta now
Shane's docu-series focused on a bunch
of different aspects of Jake Paul's life
his relationship with his family his
ex-girlfriend Alyssa violet his squad
mates and team 10 even going so far as
to analyze Jake with the help of a
licensed therapist to try and determine
whether Jake is actually a sociopath the
question that we've been asking since
2013 but across all 413 minutes of
content nearly 7 hours of video
dedicated to this guy there's one story
that Shane Dawson really missed either
because he wasn't interested in it or
frankly because he wasn't allowed to
talk about it and that's Jake Paul's
real job because here's the thing in the
docu-series Shane portrays Jake as a
vlogger a young guy out there having fun
and making cash with his buddies but
that's a huge lie Jake isn't a vlogger
nor has he ever intended to be in an
interview last year Jake Paul himself
said I want to be the first social media
billionaire and that wasn't just some
offhand remark in the style of Bruno
Mars wishing he was a billionaire that
was in the
texts of an interview discussing his
business the pursuit of money is pretty
darn central to Jake Paul's online
identity and as such it seems like a
glaring oversight in Shane's documentary
especially given how he just got a
behind-the-scenes look at Jeffrey stars
mega business no it's my theory that
Shane wasn't allowed to talk about it
because the business side of jake paul
doesn't v all that well with his goofy
on-camera persona and was thus the
untold part of this supposedly tell-all
documentary by the way i am more than
happy to pick up where shane left off
and i've left a couple of links down
below to other youtubers who've started
to talk about similar parts of this
story like nerd city and lindsay ellis
but this is all my own take on what jake
paul is really doing what he's really
selling because it is a heck of a lot
more than t-shirts so today we're not
going inside the mind of jake paul this
is us going inside the business of jake
paul to reveal how his billion-dollar
ambitions might be the first glimpse
into the future of a dystopian youtube a
youtube built on manufacturing and
monetizing the most valuable commodity
of them all trust in shane series the
first real glimpse we got
behind-the-scenes with jake paul wasn't
talking about how his pranks are staged
those pranks on them are like fake my
vlogs are like lightly scripted and so
all those pranks tell them i'm gonna do
it feel like okay and then i do it and
quite frankly that's an amateur stuff of
course it's all fake anyone who
remembers the early days of italian Rome
and know that it was all faked what he
didn't talk about being faked was his
completely carefree attitude building a
business empire isn't about Jake
clowning around in front of a camera it
requires him to act in a very deliberate
and intentional way and Jake is
certainly not a man without a larger
plan in place in a video posted on
January 2nd 2017
now unlisted Jake Paul lays out his
plans for potential investors in his new
business team dome he says we are like a
business incubation
Y Combinator and things like that but we
do that for Oh Jake I'm sure that a very
small minority of your viewers have
actually heard of Y Combinator so let me
explain it to him Y Combinator is one of
the biggest startup incubators in
Silicon Valley they provided early
funding and mentorship to companies like
Dropbox Reddit and twitch just to name a
few and of course that early investment
means that they own part of those
companies investing in a company when
it's valued at a few million dollars
starts to look like a really good idea
when that company goes on to be valued
at billions of dollars as it was the
case with Dropbox and reddit twitch on
the other hand was not part of that
billion dollar club since it sold Amazon
for a valuation of a mere nine hundred
and seventy million dollars ah
so closing it's so far the important
takeaway here though is Y Combinator
isn't a technology company it invests in
technology companies for partial
ownership Jake seems to be aiming to
copy the idea in his pitch video he
isn't trying to sell himself as an
influencer or vine star he's trying to
sell himself as a business incubator
that can train up other influencers and
become an early investor in what they're
doing in exchange owning a big chunk of
their career do you lick anything on the
internet to anybody you will be sued for
everything you have and I know I've
taken 20% of that already but you will
be sued for the rest of it if his goal
is to become a billionaire jake has the
right idea Bruno Mars might not be a
billionaire no matter how frickin bad he
wants it but you know who is Len
Blavatnik the owner of holding company
access industries who owns Warner Music
Group which in turn owns Atlantic
Records which is Bruno Mars's record
label yes I'm talking about the owner of
the owner of the owner of the owner of a
musician if you're counting those
different layers
the point is billion-dollar talents are
rare most of the world's billionaires
are businessmen the kind of people who
manage or invest in talent or other
industries only one musician in all of
history has ever passed a billion
dollars and you'll never guess who it is
it's Andrew Lloyd Webber he wasn't even
a stage performer he's a composer who
created musicals even those musicals he
mostly ripped off from other people and
before you run off to Google two fat
check that yeah it's really true even
Beyonce and t-swift aren't billionaires
know who's closer to being a billionaire
than Beyonce her husband jay-z makes
most of his money by you guessed it
owning his own record label and doing
massive business deals not by being a
cool rapper when it comes to Jake Paul's
billion-dollar idea managing his own
YouTube channel in his own career as an
influencer is small potatoes compared to
the eventual goal which he laid out in
an interview last year as he says I know
it's a cliche but like literally I want
to create an empire of dozens of talent
under me to take my power and multiply
it so I become bigger than myself
he doesn't want to just become a star
who gets attention he wants to be the
owner of a company that manages other
stars which again it seems like a pretty
good game plan if the goal is to create
a billion dollar business empire Shane
Dawson not talking about this is like
doing a documentary on Elon Musk just
talking about his personal life without
ever mentioning the words Tesla or
SpaceX now building a billion-dollar
business ain't easy but lucky for Jake
he's got himself some help in 2017 he
raised himself a small loan of a million
dollars to start up team dome who were
the investors lead investor in the
million dollar round was Dan wah a
Chinese investment firm along with Gary
Vaynerchuk who appears in the team dumb
pitch video alongside Jake Paul as well
as eight burns of sound Ventures and
Grady Investments two investment firms
co-founded by Ashton Kutcher so why does
any of this matter well it tells us
something about the future of the
company investors aren't gift givers
they're not super generous they're
really savvy people who are looking to
make money for themselves
investors can make money in a lot of
ways but they're always gonna be looking
for the biggest payouts which usually
means they're looking to sell the
company for a lot of money the way
Instagram sold itself to Facebook so why
do these investors matter to us and more
importantly to Jake's job well it means
that even though he doesn't show it a
lot of Jake's time has to be spent
behind the scenes working to make those
investors the money that they expect
he's not gonna impress them by flexing
with his Lambos all day especially when
it's those big investor dollars that
bought that Lambo in the first place
these are the people that you're not
gonna want to disappoint because they
didn't give Jake a million dollars just
so he could clown around in his big
house all day with his friends they
gave him that money because they think
it'll enable him to build a company that
some other bigger company will buy out
for a lot more money Jake can't be just
doing this thing forever because all
those people want to and more
importantly need to get themselves paid
baby there's another reason Jake paul's
investors are a big part of this whole
picture investors have an influence on
the company they give money to in the
world of retail investing where you go
on to the publicly traded stock market
buy a share of Apple for $200 simply so
you can own point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero two percent of the
company if you as a shareholder don't
really have all that much saying what
goes on an Apple you can just show up to
the shareholders meeting but it's not
like they're gonna be consulting you on
any big decisions the world of private
investment though is a different beast
unlike publicly traded companies private
investors have to strike individual
deals with the companies that they're
investing in in a lot of ways this is a
good thing when an investment firm gives
you money in exchange for part of your
company the only way for the investment
to pay off is for your company to
succeed which means that a lot of the
things they do are gonna be related to
helping those companies thrive for
instance giving those companies access
to their network of business contacts
investment firms are also usually run by
people who have their own successes in
business which means that they can serve
as effective mentors for younger
less-experienced people who might be
starting their first business the cons
of selling part of your company to
investors is that now you're literally
giving another group ownership over part
of your company which means that you
can't make decisions entirely by
yourself anymore
and investors can be much more likely to
want to have that kind of oversight when
the CEO is young inexperienced and on
the local news for starting a bunch of
couch fires in his backyard but hey you
don't have to take my word for it Jake
Paul said it himself in a video
appropriately titled
raising money from investors one thing
that's bad about raising money from
investors is obviously you're giving
away a piece of your company so you
won't have full ownership and
you know could mean that you don't have
full control of your company in short it
might seem like Jay Paul's the one who's
steering his ship but in truth he might
not actually be the one with his hands
on the wheel as someone who took someone
else's money he is beholden to make
decisions that make his investors happy
and if your investors are no longer
happy with hell they're gonna step in
and force you to make some decisions
that make them happy like for instance
you and your brothers bad behavior
starts costing your business money two
days after that I was supposed to be
doing like a brand deal for like seven
figures taken away your investors could
I don't know force you to agree to do a
docu-series that rehabilitate your image
and then differentiates you from your
brother to make you appealing to brands
again if all this is making it sound
like Jake Paul is some sort of
innovative business mastermind who's
come up with this brilliant original
idea well the idea of creating a talent
incubator isn't exactly new the idea of
savvy business runners taking in budding
talents and training them up to become
more effective entertainment products is
about as Hollywood as Hollywood gets
though for a more recent example you can
look at the modern music industry early
on record labels would Scout talent and
agents would travel around looking for
talented local musicians now you don't
need to find talent you can simply
manufacture it for example look no
further than the Backstreet Boys NSYNC
and the Spice Girls or even more
recently you can see it in the old
controlling world of kpop and J pop
grieves the new innovation here was that
music executives realized that you could
take something that usually happens
organically a bunch of people getting
together to form themselves a group that
performs original music and manufacture
it by selecting beautiful people and
then writing songs for them to perform
on stage it's hard to find a handsome
face and a good songwriter in the same
package so why not create everything
assembly line style and so it was that
video killed the radio star and our
musical performances all came to be
performed by beautiful people who have
audio engineers teach them how to sing
on pitch it didn't take long for people
to figure out the same thing could be
done with content like YouTube videos
why wait for some naturally compelling
vlogger to come along if you understand
what makes a compelling vlog rather than
waiting for it to come into existence
organically you could just hire an actor
to act like their a vlogger you don't
think you can fake that kind of thing
think again in June 2006 yeah all the
way back at the beginnings of YouTube a
channel called lonely girl 15 popped up
showing videos starring Bri who appeared
to be a relatively ordinary teenage girl
vlogging about her life and he was brief
[Music]
until it was revealed that Bree wasn't
actually Bree she was an actress Jessica
Rhodes courts portraying a fictional
character created by a group of
filmmakers one year it took one year
after the launch of YouTube for someone
to figure it out but it took another 13
years for this model to become
mainstream on the platform which brings
us back to you guessed it
Jake Paul the only difference now though
is that Jake Paul isn't applying this
model to manufacturing musical acts are
doing a cinematic project exploring
digital video he's trying to manufacture
something very different very dangerous
he's trying to manufacture your friends
in the last part of Shane Dawson's
docu-series Jake describes himself as I
was having fun and like doing whatever I
wanted but investors didn't write him a
million dollar check just to be a kid
having fun if they wrote him a check to
become a talent spotter cranking out new
influencers that everyone else can turn
a profit on except there's a difference
between influencers and celebrities
viewers view youtubers influencers not
like celebrities they view them as
friends there's a fantastic video on
this topic made by Lindsey Ellis where
she explains it like a real educational
Channel the challenge for creators is to
maintain the illusion for their
followers of feeling like they do know
this creator when reality they only know
the effect the site of the creator that
the creator has decided it is most
beneficial for you the audience to see
when your personality your persona and
your content are all being influenced by
major media investors well then it
starts to get really hard to know where
a creators personality stops and where
the corporate machine begins when it
comes to Jake Paul it's critical for him
to convince you me all of us that he's
just a dude having fun and that he's not
some wannabe business mogul who's
manipulating his audience because then
you would start to feel like you're
being sold you buy a company which is
what he really is here it's easier if a
docu-series that explores his life is
more focused on the drama his
ex-girlfriend's his ex partners his bad
behavior and not so much the business
that's operating in the background
because the viewer
might not understand it all but they
would probably get angry if they
realized how much time they've spent
watching what they thought was a real
life vlog but was actually just the cogs
of a corporate machine working its way
slowly to that billion dollar mark and
then they would get really mad when they
also remembered how much they spent on
all that merch but I'll save that for
part two in a couple of days because if
Shane's taught me anything is that I
should save the even better stuff for
next time but in the meantime remember
first to subscribe because you don't
want to miss part 2 of this expose on
the business of Jake Paul and Shane
Dawson's documentary this is a
multi-part series don't worry I'm not
gonna extend it out to eight parts like
Shane did but it's gonna be at least
three so hit that subscribe button and
write down in the comments below the
words I don't know a chicken chick I
just think it's gonna be funny there's a
restaurant nearby that's called chicken
chick and it's just a weird name for a
restaurant so do that I challenge you to
be able to do it in the next 5 seconds 5
4 3 I don't think you're gonna be able
to do both of those things in one second
done congratulations you're gonna be
notified of the next upload but also
remember even more importantly that it's
all just a theory a film theory
and cut
[Music]